ils veulent obtenir gain de cause et ils
sont présents bien avant le début de
l'audience du cumul de connaissance de
fort de france
ces résidents de la cité grenade
exaspérés ont incité la mairie d'un tube
à bouillon en référé enfin ben là
qu'arrive et parce que ça qu'a fait
depuis quinze donner des noms mais si tu
es gosnay delajoux pages au maroc et au
finish les caillots et amplifie aux
débats et aux cayes équipe l'un la
miotte et puis ambitieux découvert
kignan le parasite pour le board a donc
ça nous commandent un premier temps nous
comprennent qu'il y ait pays la mairie
l'âge ou pas bio à l'amiable cet été
réglés mais apparemment c'est pas ça
d'augmenter obligé vu ni devant un
tribunal
regardez si ballack avant si le
préjudice pour vient donc d'une part de
la tente un titre de propriété de leur
logement à la city grenade et d'autre
part de vivre depuis plusieurs années
dans des maisons dégradées construite
avec des produits cancérigènes
en l'occurrence de l'amiante c'est en
2000 dans le cadre le vaste projet de
rénovation que ce matériau dangereux est
découvert mais senti de propriété les
résidents ne peuvent bénéficier d'aucune
aide
les contrats ont été signés ce sont des
contrats de droit privé
si aujourd'hui la mue speight et décide
de le remettre en cause
comment ils vont faire pour pouvoir
justifier des loyers qu'ils ont perçues
et qu'ils ont dû déclarer
donc tout cela est du baratin la
question qui se pose c'est qu'on a une
quarantaine de familles dont 16
qu'engage la procédure qui vivent dans
des conditions indignes et que monsieur
bonté serait bien de ne pas faire du
juridisme mais de s'occuper de l'humain
c'est à dire de ces êtres qui sont en
train de vivre dans des conditions
anormales
en donner une expertise dans le but de
chiffrer le montant des travaux
l'avocat de la mairie semble aujourd'hui
adhérer à cette demande du collectif
aujourd'hui il faut chiffrer le coût du
désir montage il faut chiffrer peut-être
le coût de la reconstruction est temps
que nous aurons pas tous ces éléments et
ça a été l'objet de cette audience
aujourd'hui demandé aux juges de statuer
sur cette demande d'expertisé
en revanche cet avocat conteste la
remise des titres de propriété sous
astreinte de 200 euros par jour de
retard à l'issue de la décision de
justice
faut savoir que c'était la location
vente ou les propriétaires dont les
futurs propriétaires pour accéder à
cette à cette propriété donc n'ont pas
payé tous à temps leur location leur
loyer dont tous ne pouvaient pas accéder
à un moment donné mais je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que
aujourd'hui c'est pas tant le titre de
propriété mais savoir dans quelles
conditions ils pourront le faire
pour l'heure les membres du collectif
attendent impatiemment que l' ordonnance
soit rendue elle est mise en délibéré au
15 février